a lot of people around the office or
well they're getting kind of excited
about the Golden State Warriors playing
in the NBA Finals
so of course the Warriors are facing the
Toronto Raptors and yeah and our only I
say our only Canadian writer Levi
mcdougal who happens to be a huge
Raptors fan is also very very excited
about how well the Raptors are doing and
I thought it's such a rare thing for him
let's bring him out here because he's so
excited our Canadian writer Levi let's
get him out here well congratulations on
everything leave oh thank you pretty
cool huh so cool yeah all right so you
are I can tell you're a big Raptors fan
oh yeah big time I've been a fan since
the Carter Administration
[Applause]
you're a comedy writer okay Levi that's
Vince Carter and he hasn't played for
the rappers for like 20 years
yeah yeah I knew that okay anyway the
Raptors won Game one so if you'll excuse
me I got some Canadian trash-talking to
do wait a minute hold on hold on
hey suzi warriors say more like Golden
State Warriors yeah and I'd be worried
too if I was playing a team like the
Raptors I hope that wasn't too harsh so
you're right Oh big Warriors fan hey no
Clippers anyway your state didn't look
too golden in Game one right boom
got you although we do reside in
California and I quite enjoy it it's
beautiful
see you at lunch Hey Raptors rule
Warriors drool hope that's okay oh hey
Lisa
your team is lame good burn right
somebody better call 911 and get you to
the burn unit and guess what this one's
free cuz that's socialized health care
baby coz a mother sucks
I hope Steph Curry dies I hope you all
die and eat all the fit inhale Raptors
lost last night the series is tied
thanks for the info sorry about all that
stuff I said sorry hey sorry sorry sorry
hey Conan yeah the Raptors lost games
yeah we know we know everyone knows but
just in case the Raptors take Game three
you guys are both stinky losers okay
sorry sorry it's okay leave I walk like
it I don't know why does he walk like
this I all I know is that's a
good-looking Jersey yes
[Laughter]